hi everybody
I'm Jesse wykel and I'm a front-end
developer and this is my first live
stream for free code camp I've done some
live streams on my own channel but this
is the first one on free code camp which
is has a lot more subscribers this is an
awesome opportunity to hopefully help
some more people the goal of this live
stream is just to show you what when my
job is like as a front-end developer so
I I'm not preparing a lot of stuff in
advance on purpose because I want you to
see my mistakes and see how I work
through mistakes and frustration and
kind of fouled how ideas just come to
you when when you're working you know
sometimes sometimes you think of awesome
things that you didn't even plan because
of some difficulty that you're having so
I kind of want to show that aspect of it
so if you want to check out my other
videos I have my youtube channel up on
the screen now you can also reach me at
Twitter it's just Jesse or Weigel the
project were working on now the repos is
live you can check out the code follow
along and just to bring you up-to-date
here's the plan we're going to build a
site at first it's just going to be a
static HTML site CSS JavaScript the goal
is to convert it into a react site so we
convert everything into components I'd
like to pull data from the WordPress API
render it on the server side with react
and then have it be served to the client
already pre-rendered it'll be good for
search engines like that
but that's kind of the longer-term plan
for now we're just working with the
static site so I explained more in depth
about why I'm doing this and what we're
gonna be doing in my video yesterday so
if you want to later check that out on
my site I'm not going to go into it
again for the people that might be
tuning in that did yesterday I can see
all right you guys are really positive
in the in the comments they're so
awesome
I'm going to try to keep up with the
live chat if I can I know there's some
delay so I might already be talking
about something else by the time I see
your comments so I apologize if I'm a
little slow on that so let's get started
I'm going to show you what I'm working
on I'm taking a site that's partially
finished and I'm going to I'm going to
finish it but I'm going to redesign it a
little bit the goal is this is a site
for a department in Franciscan
University the University of self has a
style guide and brand standards for
websites and then this particular
department has a certain style that
they're trying to achieve so we need to
blend those two styles together
respecting the university's branch
standards but then trying to really stay
true to the vision of this particular
department and we have a really short
time frame for the site I want to at
least get this the static portion of
this slice done by Monday so I have a
colleague of mine setting up some
servers and things so that it will save
us some time in a later video we might
get into some of the server stuff when
we need to set up node and express and
react but for now right before I started
the stream I'm working on a header so
I'll show you let me show you the home
page quickly just
to recap from from yesterday I added a
few things remember we added this hero
image you have this picture back here
we're going to change this phone at some
point but for now it's it's okay it
works we have the sticky knife when we
scroll down and what we added were these
these cards here these image cards the
other side had had something similar not
quite with the same effects we're trying
to keep kind of like a material design
feel to things that's what at the
University we try to follow material
design patterns it just brings a nice
consistency to everything we had a
question about static websites and react
so the reason I'm building a static
website first and then moving to react
is because my timeline is so short I'm
afraid it might not be possible to build
it all out and react and get all the
custom post types and WordPress and
everything ready before we need to
launch so if I can't get it already
at least the static site will be ready
to launch the drawback is people can't
edit that content in in WordPress I'd
like to use that for the content
management because it's so easy for
people who don't know code to edit but
to kind of buy more time we're doing a
static first and then there'll be
something up it won't be as easily
editable but at least there'll be
something up for launch it will be fast
and then when we change it to react from
a user's perspective there really won't
be any difference but behind the scenes
it'll be a lot easier to to manage and
update for the people that are going to
be tasked with that so that's why I'm
doing it like that when it comes to
angular versus react I've worked with
both I haven't I've just done some some
fun side things with
angular I haven't actually done you know
production-ready sites for clients with
angular but I do like it I have actually
launched sites with react and I like it
as well so I'm a big believer in using
the tool that's best for what your
project is so if you know I don't take
sides in angular versus react so and I'm
not I don't know that I'm qualified to
go into which is best for which
situation but in this case since I'm Way
more familiar with react and we have
such a tight deadline that's you know
that's kind of the only thing I could go
with in such a short timeframe that I
knew for sure I could get launched and a
little it would work okay all right this
the home page the only other thing we
did from that's different from yesterday
is we added these little these little
background images here these were in the
original site that's partially completed
and the the client the people from the
the department the catechetical
Institute they really love these little
kind of flourishes here so we're going
to try to keep these in as much as we
can and um these are actually done with
a double background image so I'll show
you that real quick because I kind of
thought that was cool it's something
that I really learned how to do somewhat
recently so I'll show you that quickly
before we move on to new stuff here's my
I'm working with sass so it's not
straight CSS the success so it's
slightly different if you're not used to
that that type of syntax so if you see
we have two background images just
separated by a comma and then when we go
to position them we just separate the
positions with a comma as well and then
that's how we can get these two images
to be exactly where we want them and we
don't have to I think the original site
had you know nested divs with background
images
so I think this this is a cleaner way to
do it it keeps the the code is certainly
more clean to look at without all those
nested divs and all the div was really
there for was just to have the
background image it didn't serve any
other purpose so I don't know that was
kind of cool and new to me so maybe
it'll be useful for you guys and I'm
sorry I'm not keeping up that well with
with the chat this is kind of difficult
I usually don't have as many people
chatting all at once so I'll do my best
but I'd like to you know get to work and
show you some of some what I'm doing so
I'm going to go back to this page this
interior base team dot HTML so all I did
so far was I duplicated the index page
and we need to make an interior header
because the way that other header was
set up it really depended on that that
big kind of hero section and I don't
want that here a section on every single
page I don't know about you but I find
it somewhat annoying if there's like the
same big hero section on every page at
some point I just want to get to the
content without having to you know see
that section so I don't want to have a
big hero section on every page so we
need to make an alternate version of the
header for all the interior pages so
that's what I've done so all I've done
so far is just remove the hero section
and now I'm just kind of working on the
logo size and you can see it's we're
right in the middle of this we need to
make this logo I'd like to have it as
small as possible and still be readable
I'd love to have it as thin of a header
as possible so that the content is is
clearly visible we're going to keep this
part of the header a kind of sticky as
we scroll down just like on the home
page and then that will give us a nice
slim header but it'll still allow people
to navigate anywhere in the site and
without having to scroll all the way up
we also have in place to scroll to top
button once you scroll down so far so I
mean that that will be useful as well
it's nice to have both of those options
so people can navigate really quickly
okay so let's get to it I'm going to
become a switching switching around a
little bit here and I'm going to bring
in dev tools such as chrome dev tools
here for this site and right now I was
just looking at this image and just kind
of trying to mess with the size so I'm
going to try to take this down
let's try take it down to 70 pixels do
have some smaller you know really thin
font here so we might not be able to get
away with it being that that small I
Alexander just says he likes Adam better
than sublime text I like Adam as well
I've never used sublime text mainly just
because sublime text cost money and Adam
didn't and when I started to really get
into front-end development I was on my
own and freelancing and pretty broke at
first so I always preferred the free
stuff but I think both of them from what
I've seen of other other developers
using sublime text they're pretty
similar but I can't speak to it from my
own experience I've also use Visual
Studio code whenever I have to work on
like.net projects I usually use Visual
Studio code mainly because I just it was
faster than trying to get the right
package for Adam to do the same type of
syntax highlighting that Visual Studio
code did right off the bat okay so we
shrunk that down to 70 and now let's
take this this navbar and we'll make it
a little bit taller there we go
and the brand logo I think we can get
away with a smaller margin at the top
and that'll save us some space so we'll
take that down all the way we we've
decreased that top margin by 50% there
that'll buy us a lot of space and then
that means we can come in here and we
can make this just a bit smaller okay
that's nice I name is probably about as
good as we're going to get for now the
last thing we need to do let's see
need to figure out why this isn't going
up you'll find as I do these videos a
lot of it it's just trying to figure out
what is going on on the page I am using
a framework I'm using materialized as a
framework I like that because it has the
material design style is kind of built
right in and that's why you see all
these classes and everything a lot of
that's already built in I definitely if
you have a site where you need a lot of
functionality that a framework can give
you I recommend it it saves you it saves
so much time I think it's kind of cool
to make a site entirely from scratch and
it can be really fast and awesome but
the reality is sometimes you just have
tight deadlines and you can't do it like
that okay where is this coming from
well let's just check this out see maybe
I have it never the line oh I can't
figure that out right now so let's come
in here and make some of these changes
here that I just made over here in dev
tools
all right I'm going to move their tools
off to the side here for a second just
so I can copy the same changes we just
made over into our live our live code
here and I'm using gulp to do the live
reload so every time we edit this it'll
automatically refresh this page okay so
here's right now if we want to go down
that's the original nav that's the home
page but we want to go down here to
interior so I've given the header tag
let me bring up the HTML so you guys can
see that too okay so we've given the
header the class of interior so
everything else for this interior thing
is going to fall within this and we nest
things we're using sass everything's
kind of nested makes it easier to write
things like this the CSS that comes out
afterwards that's generated can look a
little weird at times with lots of tags
but the development process for me at
least is a lot faster using sass okay so
here's what we did we made that nav will
we get 88 pixels as the height and
excuse any sloppiness in the code
usually I try to go and clean this stuff
up after our live stream so don't spend
a lot of my time just worrying about
indentation and style okay we need that
okay we got the margin bottom there and
so I think all we need to change is the
brand logo image and we drop that down
to 70 pixels and then for the brand logo
itself for that it's actually an a tag
that contains the the image we drop that
top margin down to 8 pixels
from 16
okay
okay I'm reading a little bit of your
conversation here did I make a plan or
plan my planning on the go I am planning
a bit on the go so the overall plan is
is set but the little details we have to
take this on the go I just found out
yesterday morning that I was going to be
taking on this project and it needs to
be done by Monday so I kind of have to
plan a little bit on the go and in this
case I am a little bit of a designer and
a developer I don't I don't actually
work with a web designer so most of them
most what I do is kind of a combination
of design and development that's why I
do like to go with material design a lot
because I don't really consider myself a
designer so a lot of these design
decisions
I just rely on the material design
framework for it saves me a lot of time
and it lets me have consistency okay so
great that all worked we save that and
[Music]
not we need to really need to figure out
why this gap is here so I like to go in
when I'm trying to figure that this kind
of thing out to the computed tab and
then that way I can see this and I just
run through all my elements and try to
figure out which there we go see when I
did that I can see the height of the
element here and then I can also see the
highlight that blue highlight and I can
see that's my problem there is that I
have a height on my header which is the
container for all the nav stuff I need
to get rid of that height I need to drop
that down I need to get rid of it
completely let's see I think that's
probably the best thing we'll just get
rid of the height we don't need it on
there we have the interior element here
nav we have the height for the
oops so let's do that let's go up we'll
go here and we'll set height hmm let's
try this if I can I'd like to just get
rid of that height entirely and we might
be able to so I'm going to go all the
way up here to the original header and
I'm just going to comment this up
quickly and I want to look at local hoes
oops
okay I need three thousand one okay
great so that's not really going to
affect the homepage either so that was
just some code left over that we didn't
really need this was copied over most of
this markup was copied over from a
template that I created that had some of
the basic Styles that the university
likes to use and I created a template so
that if I needed to do this like quickly
I could just download the template it's
available on my github profile I can
download that template and get right
right to work and not have to worry
about a lot of you know the normal
things that you do every time you do a
site so there's there's definitely going
to be some CSS JavaScript and HTML that
are unnecessary and we'll clean that up
when we get a chance before we launch
okay I keep it on my time we get about
nine minutes left let's see how much we
can get done okay we're back here
alright this headers is okay I think
we're kind of boarding bordering here on
unreadable 'ti with this logo here we
may have to make it a little bit bigger
but I think it's good enough right now
to give us an idea of how it will be
this section here could probably be
thinner so that's another area where we
could you know save on some height
I think this is a yeah this this is thin
enough we may add some things over here
if we need to this is a great place
maybe for call-to-action button so great
so you see that's thinking I was working
and for this page this is going to be a
team page so for every page there's
interior page is going to be a title I'd
like to have a place where that title is
going to be either right here or
potentially if we have all this black
area up here we we could have it here
you know it might look nice to kind of
tie it together if we took that same
background image from the hero section
and we popped it in right here on this
side we have to shrink it down a little
bit but I think that's worth to try to
see how it looks and it shouldn't be too
hard because we we already have a lot of
the mark-up for that to be the
background sums can go in here and I'm
going to find that hero section and we
had it we gave it an idea of hero right
now my SAS is basically in the order it
appears on the page that the elements
here on the page when this all gets
converted to react you know all this
won't matter we're going to try to make
the components a self-contained as
possible and break the CSS up so I'm not
that worried about organization at this
point so let's just grab all these
background properties and I'm not going
to worry about these media queries we're
going to use different sizes I had to
make vid sizes yet but eventually we're
going to use different sizes depending
on the screen width and we'll probably
want to do that with this other nav as
well I'm not going to do it right now
since we're running a little bit short
I'd like to at least get this in there
so we can see what it looks like
oops here we go with this interior
and let's go on Ave and let's copy this
all in it's gonna look weird at first I
think but then oh slowly nothing at
first
alright let's see what's going on here
let's check the nav out okay we have the
image there let's see let's just start
taking off some of these let's see if we
can huh try to take off as much as I can
just to see if we could look we can see
it see why it's not working soon okay at
least we can see it now so we know is
there we definitely don't want that but
I mean how cool would that have looked
in the 90s and that would have been
awesome I'm going to what I really
wanted to do is just convey over here so
we're definitely going to click that no
repeat for the background here we can
see it's on this side right now we don't
want it on that side so let's go to this
background position X and this make lets
us move it from one side to the other so
the background position X is at 183
percent right now so let's just let's
just do something simple and say write
great okay so that puts it on the right
we'll go back to your percentage when we
need to really position it you know more
accurately but for now this puts it
where we want it it's definitely too
small so let's go back to this this
height prep and nope that's not what I
wanted um background size let's see what
we're going to do with the size of it
okay what we might need to do with the
size let's go with let's just see if we
can get it to look right here hmm
exactly
all right so I can't see that at all
right now the specter background covered
I had gotten the same issue with the
hero section I think I did that off not
on a live stream so this is kind of what
happens especially when you're kind of
designing and developing on the go
together sometimes you just keep
changing values to see what happens so
oh I had it contain okay we've got three
minutes let's see let's turn that fixed
back on I think they don't want to fix I
think I want that off for the hero
section we put set a background
attachment fixed property and that kind
of gave us a little parallax effects you
can see that that here but I don't think
we want that with the header I don't
think that's um
I don't think that would be expected
behavior for you know just that header
section anyway so we're going to get rid
of that let me just take that out of
there right now and when we get it right
we'll just copy and paste this whole
thing over and let's see background
sighs oh I see what we did I never took
out the original background sighs
property that we had for the hero
section so let's remember to clean that
up at some point okay but now we can
change the size here and see see what's
going on and then the background
position why there we go okay how so I
thought so now we can see we've got this
this image here
we just need to mess with the sizes a
bit so I'm gonna bring this position
back back up again
oops accidentally just put that I'll
just take one of them out because we
have it already on that element okay so
let's see
I think I needs to be a little bit
smaller let's see you
okay all right I don't love that I think
it maybe needs a little bit of work but
that gives us an idea of what it might
look like you know over here we'll have
to check it on when it shrinks actually
that that kind of even works on a
smaller okay it finally starts to
overlap here so we'll definitely have to
do something about that when we get you
notice a more narrow screen but for now
that gives us a good idea kind of the
direction we want to go with that header
all right so we have about a minute left
I okay somebody said Thanks yeah you're
welcome
um so I'm glad you guys watched it looks
like this there's a ton of people
watching so I'm super excited about that
thanks for all the conversation I'm
sorry I couldn't keep up with it I'm
gonna go back after this and read
through everything and maybe I can
respond in the comments and if you have
any questions just you know comment I'll
try to get to them as much as I can
Brian Sizemore is brought to you by G
fuel he works with me and he knows that
before my live streams I drink G fuel
it's an energy drink so I don't sound
like I'm I'm half asleep so anyway I
don't want to go too far over 30 minutes
so I think that's super long to try to
watch a video thanks again for watching
I'll be back tomorrow every day at 2
p.m. unless some emergency comes up I'm
going to be streaming Monday through
Friday 2 p.m. Eastern Time
there'll be a recording available right
after that it will automatically post to
the channel so at at about 2:30 the
recording will be there and I'll either
be on this channel on free code camp or
I'll be on my own channel if you just
look up Jesse Weigel in YouTube it will
be the first bunch of videos that come
up probably I think there's one other
Jesse
I go on YouTube right now so I'll see
you guys tomorrow I'll be back tomorrow
and hopefully I'll have more of this
site done because it needs to be done
but I had a great time and let me know
if there's any tips for me I'm still
pretty new at this live-streaming thing
so definitely any tips are are very
welcome all right so I'll end the stream
now thanks again have a great day I'll
be back tomorrow
[Music]